if governments don't completely
eliminate fossil fuels by 2040
society is doomed says jeff nesbitt
author of this
is the way the world ends that kind of
apocalyptic rhetoric costs us trillions
hurts the poor and fails to fix the
planet
says bjorn lombor the author of false
alarm
are fossil fuels an imminent threat to
human life or are attempts to eliminate
them
more destructive that was the subject of
an oxford style
online soho forum debate hosted on
sunday october
18 2020. arguing in favor of the
complete elimination of fossil fuels
over 20 years was nesbitt who's the
executive director of climate nexus
he went up against lomborg who's the
president of the copenhagen consensus
center
here's jeff nesbitt and bjorn lomborg in
an online debate
moderated by soho farm director gene
epstein
[Music]
again tonight's resolution reads to
combat
climate change the world's leaders must
make it
their highest priority to completely
replace
the burning of fossil fuels within the
next
20 years i'll be keeping track of time
to debaters and we'll briefly interrupt
each of you
to say when you have five minutes left
and one minute left
uh jeff you're first up
to defend the resolution jane please
close the initial vote and take it away
jeff
okay great so i wanted to thank you all
for for
for uh letting me talk to you uh this
evening about meeting the climate moment
and why we um why i'm arguing with that
we need to go as fast as we can
as as quickly as we can
today i'm not going to talk about ipcc
reports
parts per million of carbon dioxide 2
degrees celsius
climate models cap and trade schemes
carbon taxes
economic theory or polar bears
instead i'm going to start with my book
it's called this is the way the world
ends and i'll just a quick note for
those of you who
are authors i did not choose the the
title for this book my publisher did i
think i'm oh for 27 with my books
in terms of titles for my books so um
but i wrote the book to shift the
discussion i wanted to
i wanted to shift the discussion with
thought leaders with the media
i wanted to describe how
um i wanted to describe how climate
impacts are happening
right now not not 50 years from now
so we all we all see it right now we see
climate change
with our own eyes hurricanes are
stronger and faster
wildfires are more intense extreme
flooding is catastrophic
heat waves are scarier ice shelves are
melting more
sea levels and storm surges are rising
and on hurricanes i
i just want to say this i'm i'm not
saying there are more of them
or even that climate change is causing
them what i'm saying is that
climate change is making them worse
and the impacts are here right now not
40
or 50 years from now they're
dramatically affecting water resources
across the planet
they're impacting hundreds of millions
of species right now
they're driving dangerous geopolitical
strategies
which i talk a lot about in my book and
i'll get to those in just a second
they're creating huge climate risks for
businesses
insurance companies and financial groups
virtually every species on earth is on
the move
half of all species are experiencing
local extinctions
right now and for those who don't know
what local extinctions art means when a
species can't move
fast enough can't migrate fast enough
they go extinct
in that part of the world about 80
percent of migrating species are doing
so
because of quote physical constraints on
their habitats
extinction rates are a hundred times
what we might expect
two-thirds of all species on earth have
shifted to
earlier spring breeding migrating or
blooming
earth's third pole the himalayas is
under serious duress
um the himalayas for those who are
familiar with it they're they're really
the engine of the climate system
they're the primary source of water for
a billion people
temperature increases there are now
double the global average
glaciers that took thousands of years to
grow or vanishing
in just 25 years and in fact and i
talked about this in the book the
chinese
just opened up their research that
they've had underway in the himalayas
for the last 50 years or so
and hundreds of glaciers in the one
small part of the himalayas they studied
have entirely vanished uh in the past
generation
and that's um so if you extrapolate from
there that means that thousands of
smaller glaciers have disappeared
entirely
the melting rate for the biggest
glaciers is accelerating
it's doubled in just one generation
the world's pollinators are disappearing
as well and that's not good so
climate change is crushing bumblebee
species in both
north america and europe this comes from
um
a united nations a special report
with experts on pollinators that they
gathered on an emergency basis to study
what's happening with the pollinators
and what they found is that they've
retreated 200 miles from their historic
ranges
in just a generation but that still
quite honestly isn't fast enough
nearly all of the 20 000 species of
pollinators
are equally stressed hundreds of
billions of dollars from our food supply
every single year are at risk
so what about climate's evil twin ocean
acidification for the longest time
the two were not linked ocean health
ocean acidification
and climate change up in the atmosphere
really were not linked but folks have
started to do that very closely
first of all oceans are a carbon sink
and second of all
they can actually affect what goes on in
the atmosphere
550 billion tons of carbon dioxide have
dissolved in the oceans
um since the since the pre-industrial
revolution
times that's a dangerous change in its
chemistry
oceans have grown 30 percent more acidic
in the past 100 years
that's the fastest change we've ever
discovered
we've all heard about the collapse of
the great coral reefs that's been
documented
quite well but the last time we saw
ocean chemistry changes like this
55 million years ago during a mass
extinction event
and just one final note i'd like to add
phytoplankton has dropped
six percent in 30 years and
as if you know ocean chemistry
phytoplankton is what's what drives
oxygen
um in the oceans it's and it's all that
that
that level six percent in 30 years is
already affecting oxygen levels
meanwhile the arctic is changing right
before our eyes i know folks
early on in the climate uh discussion
started to focus on polar bears i'm not
talking about polar bears here
permanent ice which is known as
multi-year ice
has shrunk 20 percent to just 2 percent
in 30 years the jet stream's been
wobbling for a decade now
and that jet stream wobbling effect
affects extreme weather events in both
north america
and europe the truth sadly is this
the arctic is going through an ecosystem
regime change
right now a big pivotal study that was
that involved a half dozen countries
recently found
19 separate ecosystem shifts underway
at an unprecedented pace the great green
wall in north africa
it's uh which is was conceived as
literally hundreds of millions of trees
around the desert
it won't save the sahel despite that
four billion dollar pledge
to build a wall of trees around the
desert it won't save the nations in
around
the sahel and one caveat when i
started to research my book i really
believed that that pledge
would help that you'd have those trees
they would they would they would hold
back the desert
the truth is it doesn't in one example
which i described in the book
they planted 15 million trees uh in one
of the countries around
in the sahel and they died within three
months um
so that's not going to solve this
problem thousands of farms are being
swallowed up two-thirds of africa's
arable land
could be lost in just the next 10 years
half of the world's population now
depends on food imports so all of this
has profound implications in that part
of the world
most of us now see what are called domes
of heat on a regular basis
cities in the sub tropics and again the
the subtropics is where climate
scientists have said for quite some time
that we're going to start to see the
most severe impacts from global warming
so right now cities in the subtropics
keep setting records
for the hottest temperatures in human
history record highs
outnumber record lows now two to one
that imbalance
you would expect it to be 50 roughly 50
50 is one of the clearest
climate signals we have in fact
meteorologists
had to add a new zone for australia
australia a purple zone on top of their
existing
graphics and charts heat waves kill tens
of thousands
every few years now on a regular basis
category six hurricanes and by the way
there is no such thing as a category six
hurricane
um it's you only go to category five but
if there were category six hurricanes
and you know and there were that chart
um they're just around the corner in
fact we've probably already seen a few
hurricanes now intensify much faster and
they drop more rain they're fueled
by warmer oceans they're carrying eight
percent more water
circulating in the atmosphere which
which is what
drives these extreme precipitation
events
which means that some coastal cities are
becoming uninsurable right now
because of the risk of catastrophic
flooding
water wars have already begun in the
subtropics and i spend a lot of time on
this on the on the geopolitical
implications
of climate impacts right now throughout
the subtropics
climate scientists in fact and
environmental groups saw yemen's civil
unrest coming
before others did when the water ran out
the internal wars began
saudi arabia has drained its aquifer
it's effectively out of water and
granted
there are multiple reasons for that they
grew wheat when they shouldn't have they
drained the aquifer
they traditionally don't give very much
rain but climate is
sits over the top like the 800 pound
gorilla and
has and has driven them to this
situation it's one of the reasons again
why they're buying land for food
in places like arizona there's there's
scouring for land for food up and down
denial right now a multi-year drought in
syria drove farmers off the land and
into the cities
that in turn created a political crisis
water scarcity in jordan
is making the palestinian refugee
problem much worse again
i'm not saying that climate change is
the cause of that
but it's certainly driving it combined
with
mistakes that they're making on water
distribution and how they're dealing
with their water infrastructure
water scarcity also creates instability
the lack of water and somalia has made
it nearly uninhabitable and very
dangerous
pakistan and india have nearly gone to
war over water issues in kashmir
a water war there seems inevitable in
india there are emerging scientific
studies that show the monsoon might
become unstable
that will affect a billion people and
because of the situation with the gobi
desert
china is now buying virtually every
soybean on the planet
these are some of the geopolitical
stories i talk about in my book
and i want to be clear about this these
are very real costs they are affecting
much more than just a small fraction of
the global economy
right now but there is some good news in
all of this we have a blueprint
we'll need 90 trillion dollars in new
infrastructure in the next 15 years this
is going to happen whether we have a
climate and clean energy strategy or not
and i'll add
this build out isn't based on
hypothetical economic theories it's
based on need
we have two political conversations
going on right now they're on parallel
tracks
environmentalists focus focus on climate
change the business and investment
community focuses on
energy and cost i've been arguing for
years
that we need just one conversation and
to really make this work we need a
transition we have to go from green
to blue we need to change the paradigm
from green or save the planet
to blue which effectively means save
humanity we have the technological
communications
and science capacity world output has
doubled since 1980
hundreds of millions have been lifted
out of poverty but two and a half
billion people
still live on less than two dollars a
day they're the energy poor and i'll say
this right now
of course we should focus on their needs
we also need to recognize this the age
of fossil fuels
is coming to an end we have the
technological capacity to replace fossil
fuels
for electricity and cars within 15 years
microgrids and battery storage can power
the energy
energy needs for the energy poor utility
companies are choosing renewable energy
over natural gas right now
transportation companies are placing
similar bets
and they're not betting on fossil fuels
so are major financial institutions
they finally see both the climate risks
and
economic opportunity a renewable energy
future
is in reach right now wind sunlight and
water sources
are 55 times what we need each year by
2030 10 years from now
analysts say we'll need 17 terawatts of
energy in the year 2030.
we have 667 terawatts of available solar
wind and water energy right now utility
minutes
five minutes utility scale sold thanks
gene
utility scale solar and wind energy is
now cost competitive
it'll be the cheapest new build in
within five years
electric vehicles are also at that
inflection point it's why california
just banned
gas-powered cars by 2035. others will
follow
and i'd like to say this synthetically
while i'm nuts well i'm certainly not
opposed to it
we do not need breakthrough technology
we don't need to research this for 30
years
we just need to deploy what we have now
and i'll tell you china gets it they're
racing toward a clean energy future
china said they'll peak carbon dioxide
emissions before 2030.
they see a major disruption of current
electric power and car business models
by 2030. china is doubling its renewable
energy capacity each year now
it'll add more generating capacity for
renewals renewables by 2035 than the
united states europe
and japan combined because of this clean
energy solutions will
they'll receive two-thirds of the five
trillion dollars invested
in new power plants in the next 10 years
so if you don't believe that change can
happen very quickly i want you to think
about this google and amazon
incorporated in 1995.
both of them had upended established
industries
within 15 years google offered the new
york times a 25
stake early on the new york times said
no they didn't see the internet
threatening publishing
tech industry titans like facebook
google and amazon
now dominate the global economy and it
took less than 20 years
a clean energy economy is truly the next
big thing and the analysts
see it energy exploration and cheap
power drove the global economy in the
19th century
the tech industry drove it in the 20th i
would argue clean energy
is poised to be the 21st century's
economic
opportunity and no one honestly wants to
be the next blockbuster or sears
or toys r us borders minolta or
kodak the truth is decarbonizing the
economy will create
jobs there's a recent report by a group
called rewiring america
that shows electrifying everything in
america by 2035 that's 15 years from now
creates 25 million jobs electrifying
everything would also
save the average family 2 000 a year in
energy costs
all 50 states in america can transition
to 90
clean energy in just 15 years with no
additional consumer costs
it's why clean energy jobs are growing
nearly twice as fast
as any other sector sector in america
even the oil and gas majors now clearly
see this
uh see that they see this future bp just
announced it'll increase its low carbon
business investment ten-fold
in the next decade it'll increase its
investments in this area five billion
dollars a year
and it will immediately shrink its oil
and gas production by
40 percent so do other oil and gas
majors royal dutch shell
eni of italy total of france repsol of
spain
ecuador of norway all 10-year targets
which leaves exxon and mobile and
chevron to fight for oil for the next 20
to 30 years
so i'll say right off the bat that it's
true it could take 20 years to switch
out a billion internal combustion engine
cars
but the electric vehicle trend is
accelerating and it's impossible to
ignore
tesla's battery that might last a
million years and cars that compete on
price
are obvious examples and volkswagen is
clearly becoming
an electric vehicle company now so are
others
meanwhile the age of electric cars is
dawning ahead of schedule battery prices
are dropping much faster than analysts
expected 80
in just 12 years analysts also say
electric vehicles
won't need government incentives in the
near future vw's id3
same price as a golf tesla model 3 same
as a bmw
3 series china's neo company sees price
parity
in just three years by 2023 and when
electric vehicle prices match internal
combustion
engine sticker prices across the board
the race to switch
is on so i'll predict this renewable
energy will win the fight with fossil
fuels
in less than 20 years berkeley had a
2035 grid study that shows all 50 states
in america
can reach 90 percent renewable
empowerment in just 15 years
the rockefeller foundation has a
microgrid solution to solve india's
cheap power needs
even the airline industry is
decarbonizing airbus will have zero
carbon prices
um zero carbon planes within 15 years
the world's fortune 500 companies see it
as well facebook google apple microsoft
unilever all have 20 30 targets others
are moving even faster
the us commodities future trading
trading commission
has a new report that sees climate risks
and this is what financial institutions
are finally seeing
chase morgan stanley blackrock bank of
america citibank
all are looking to invest hundreds of
billions of dollars to look at climate
risk transparency
or to study their emissions even huge
numbers of americans want to act right
now
two-thirds across the board they want
100 clean energy they want congress to
act they want climate policies to spur
innovation
they want a multi-trillion dollar
stimulus and they even want
to retrain workers in fossil fuel
industries or lose their jobs
so to closing we have a choice a clean
energy future is within our grass we
have the technology the investment
incentives
and the political will there's no reason
at all to rely on fossil fuels
for much longer disruptive energy sector
changes can clearly happen
on 20-year time horizons and the clean
energy transition designed to meet this
climate moment
will be no different and i'm certain we
can meet that challenge and then one
last uh set of slides yeah if you're
about 50 seconds 30 seconds in the hole
all right but i just want to show these
just really quickly this is fifth avenue
yes this is fifth avenue in new york
during the easter parade at the turn of
the 20th century
the parade was all horse-drawn carriages
ten years later
same same easter parade same fifth
avenue they were all cars
change can occur that rapidly thanks all
right thanks jeff
uh bjorn i'm going to give you an extra
45 seconds
to match uh jeff's uh and hopefully
you'll make the most of those extra 45
seconds
uh uh speaking for the negative uh john
lemberg
take it away bjorn good uh and jeff
thanks a lot for your presentation i'm
very glad that it also
took a little bit of time to get your
slides up and running so now i can
now i can fumble around as well so yeah
okay by the way i got
a thing at the start so so you know so
uh for taking time to set it up just i
just just wanted to say that yeah
you guys you guys have been great you
guys
jeff let let you unspiel on thanks very
thank you guys so look first of all uh
let's
and and uh you know i i had to prepare
these slides before i knew what jeff was
going to talk about so let me just
uh most of it is going to address
directly what jeff talks about
uh but let's just get this out of the
way climate change is real it's man-made
it is a problem
so our conversation really here is a
question of policy
so the question is should we eliminate
fossil fuels
in 20 years and to answer that
i think we need to look at a few key
points so let me just summarize
what i'm going to go through here the
first one of course is how big
is the challenge of climate change
jeff's presentation
makes you believe my god this is really
sort of end of the world kind of stuff
that's not the correct answer it's a
moderate problem in the world of
problems big and small it is an issue
it's not the end of the world
and that of course matters in the terms
of how much are we willing to spend on
this
then the second question is how much
good will this
end fossil fuels in 20 years do how much
good will it actually produce
i will show you the evidence from the
u.n climate panel
that indicates that this will do some
good roughly if we adjust it towards the
global gdp it will roughly be equivalent
to each one of us becoming about two
percent better off
remember when i'm measuring this in gdp
doesn't mean that everything is
measurable in gdp
it simply means it gives us an
understanding of what is the size of
this when you try to incorporate
all the different challenges many of the
non-markets many of them
you know disappearing wetlands and many
other problems
so also how much bad will this proposed
policy
do because obviously it has cost and
i'll get back to that because jeff sort
of alluded to
maybe it won't cost money at all it will
but how much
will it cost well turns out that it will
have quite a lot of cost
likely around 16 of gdp
now spending 16 of gdp to avoid
two percent cost is a bad deal
that's the fundamental reason why this
is a very bad proposal
this does not mean we should not be
focusing on and i'm
a little surprised that my um my clicker
doesn't work anymore
um yes this is what i this is the kind
of thing that you don't want to see
apparently my uh my computer just
decided to
uh halt so overall more bad than good
and we should still do climate policy
and i'll get back to that but we should
do it
smartly i'm not sure my computer seems
to be freezing up a little bit anyway
so how big a problem let me go through
these three points that i tried to make
so the first one is
what is the big environmental problems
let's just take a look at the
uh how is the world's most deadliest
environmental problems a lot of people
would tend to believe
that that's global warming they'd be
very very wrong
so very clearly some of the biggest
problems is indoor and outdoor air
pollution
which is only marginally related to
fossil fuel use it's about 20
that comes from fossil fuel use unsafe
water lead
unsafe sanitation hand washing ozone
only then
comes global warming at about 140 000
this is the world health organization
estimate from 2020 the rest of the
global burden of disease
2019 yes global warming will in 2050
be a little higher up to about 250
000 but it'll still be much much smaller
so it's important to have a sense of
proportion
yes global warming is a problem by no
means it's not the most important
environmental problem
it is indeed not the world's biggest
problem by any standard of course
the biggest problem in the world is
arguably poverty which kills about
a third of all people that die every
year so again we need to get a sense of
proportion
this does not make global warming
unimportant but it makes it very
important that we don't over focus
on global warming to the detriment of
all the other challenges that we face
this is also why when the un asked the
world this is the biggest
uh survey that we've had they asked
about 10 million people what are your
top priorities
this is the answer that people across
across the world gave us
they told us it's education health jobs
corruption nutrition
whereas action and climate change came
out at the very bottom of 16 of 16.
again we're an advanced civilization it
doesn't mean we can't
do many things at once but it's
important that we don't over focus
on global warming and again then why
do we know how big of an impact global
warming has well we do that because
climate economics have been spending the
last 30 years uh this is from last year
and a report in 2014
it's also from the only climate
economist who got the nobel prize nord
house will nordhaus at yale
uh who's done these estimates uh and
again i'm sorry
it looks like uh it shifted a little bit
because i just moved it to another
computer but there you are
it's roughly true so what it shows is as
te
as as temperatures get higher and higher
you get more and more negative impact in
the world
uh this is nord house best estimate of
what the total damage cost is
what it tells you is at a realistic
impact we're going gonna see somewhere
between two and four percent
of total global decline in
gdp from global warming that is a
problem but again
not by any means the end of the world
and this is not just nord house model
this is also
uh what the page in the fun model shows
these are three models that the obama
administration used
as its foundation to make uh an estimate
for the
social cost of carbon so if we
have this set up and we hear that global
warming is going to cost us
a couple percent but not this end of the
world stuff you got to ask yourself why
is it that i hear something entirely
different
in the news and you also heard that from
nesbitt's presentation just a little
while ago
well the answer is that we often hear
the story without adaptation let me just
show you this one
study but there's many many many of
these studies if we look at flooding
that was one of the things that jeff
mentioned flooding right now is
estimated to cost about 3.4 million
people being flooded
the cost is about 11 billion dollars in
cost of
13 billion dollars in diet cost per year
that leads to a total cost of 0.05
percent of global gdp
from flood cost that's not as big as i
think you might have imagined
but it's not trivial however if you then
look at a world
that is going to be much warmer that
will have much higher population
and much higher cost what will happen at
sea levels wise this is the typical
answer that you hear
that because we do not adapt you will
actually have
huge costs you will see a a situation
where 187 million people are going to
get flooded every year
it'll have a cost of 55 trillion dollars
uh this is the typical argument that you
hear with no adaptation
five percent of global gdp a hundred
fold increase in costs
but what that neglect of course is that
we will adapt all of these models assume
that we will adapt and this is what you
actually
see if we adapt we will see fewer people
flood it we will see
higher costs yes but that's mostly
because we're richer we'll also see much
higher cost
from dike cost but overall the total
cost and proportion of gdp
will actually decline almost tenfold
what that tells you is that you hear
stories that are very very good for
headlines that gets great amounts of
attention
but that are not realistic global
warming again is a problem it would be a
disaster if we did nothing to
towards it but it's not going to be a
disaster because nobody imagines
that we're going to do nothing about it
that's why global warming
is a moderate problem and then one we
need to ask
well how much is going to cost us to
actually tackle it so how much good will
we get from this proposed policy
uh proposal well we know that many of
the policies
that you think will have a lot of impact
actually
will do fairly little even extreme
policies like uh
all of the rich world stop all their co2
emissions tomorrow
if you run that through the u.n climate
panel model it will reduce temperatures
by the end of the century by just 0.8
degree fahrenheit
much less than what most people would
probably imagine
so how much good will this cost well
ending fossil fuels in 20 years will
likely land us around 2 degrees
centigrade
we know how much good that will do
because the un climate panel report from
2018
actually very specifically tells us if
we do
nothing it will cost the world it will
cause
further damages of two point six percent
if we get to two degrees
it'll get us to zero point five percent
instead so doing nothing will cost
damage
worth two point 2.6 ending fossil fuels
in 20 years will cause damage worth 0.5
percent
so the benefit will be to avoid
2.1 percent of gdp damages
that's the simple answer to what's the
cost of what's the benefit
but there'll also be a cost of course
there's a cost and here i think we need
to
address head-on uh something that jeff
also uh
uh seems to indicate that oh my god this
is going to be cheap
well no across europe we've seen that
the more renewable energy you put in
the higher the cost this is not because
individual solar panels are not
cheaper they are much cheaper now than
they used to be and they're possibly
even
cheaper than new fossil fuels but of
course
it's only cheaper when the sun is
shining when the sun is not shining
it's actually infinitely costly and
that's why you
can't actually easily supply the world
with renewable energy
that's also why when the un climate
panel did their modeling
they found that of 128 models
all 128 models had real cost
so the story that you often hear is the
standard slightly schizophrenic story
on the one hand renewables will
inevitably take over as they get cheaper
and on the other hand that this is going
to be a herculean world war ii
sort of mobilization kind of effort i
think uh
actually that jeff landed most in the
top one that this is going to be
cheap we don't even need to have this
conversation then of course i wonder why
we're having this debate because then we
don't need to decide anything
it's just going to happen there's a
little bit of truth and a lot of
misdirection that argument
no this is going to be phenomenally
expensive and i'll show you why
we do have estimates not for how much
this is going to cost but we do have
reasonable estimates of
some policy estimates that are close to
this
so let me just show you how absurd this
proposal that we're going to
stop in in 20 years uh let me go back to
1800
uh when in 1800 we got almost all of the
world's energy
from renewable energy and 94 we've spent
the last 170 years
getting rid of renewables and for the
last 50 years
we've stayed pretty stably at about 13
to 14
this is mostly uh developing countries
using bad fuels like wood dung
cardboard inside their homes to cook and
keep warm
even today we're at 14 percent
renewables
if we look at the paris agreement this
is the international energy agency if we
totally fulfill paris we'll get almost
to 20
more realistically to about 16 if you
look at all the un
uh basic scenarios they have five
scenarios
we will in the very best scenario get to
45
by the end of the century so this is
important to get a sense of proportion
over the last
three sorry last 200 years in the next
hundred years
we're basically likely to get rid of
fossil fuels in the very best case maybe
get back to 50
however what jeff wants you to do
is to do this go from about fourteen
percent today
to a hundred percent in two decades this
is not going to happen
but if we try to estimate how much is
this going to cost
it is going to be phenomenally costly we
don't know exactly how much because
there's
literally nobody has ever costed such an
extreme policy
but there are two other studies that do
indicate
what the cost is to get eighty percent
below
uh 1990 levels by 2050 so a longer
timeline
and less ambitious timeline will cost
somewhere between five and ten percent
of gdp every year uh to get to a hundred
percent to by 2050 so
100 that jeff proposes but further down
the line for new zealand
will cost somewhere between 16 and 32
of gdp so it's realistic
that this will be very costly and of
course it will fail
to get implemented for a very simple
reason remember the washington post
last year uh asked people and we have
many of these surveys
uh they found that uh two-thirds of all
americans think that global warming is
really important and if you ask them
as jeff posed the question do you want a
a trillion dollar
uh uh green package they'll say yes but
if you actually ask them will you pay
for it
they'll say no more than half of the u.s
population weren't willing to spend
24 a year remember the
uh uh biden climate package is gonna
cost
about fifteen hundred dollars per person
in the u.s
and of course getting these uh uh these
uh
sixteen percent of gdp uh even just five
percent of gdp
in in the us by 2050 will cost
about 12 500 per person
per year thank you so no this is not
going to happen
and that's of course why we need to
recognize look the cost of the policy
ending fossil fuels will vastly be
outweighed
will vastly outweigh its benefits that
doesn't mean
we shouldn't do anything it means we
should start tackling climate change
smartly and so let me just very briefly
say what we should be doing
we should have a realistic carbon tax i
know that jeff has talked about 40
per ton uh i probably think that's a
little optimistic but let's just go with
that but that's certainly not going to
solve all the problems we should also
look at adaptation
and mostly we should look at lots of
green innovation i'm sure that's one of
the
places we're going to be discussing jeff
told you we have all the technology we
need no we don't
uh and and there's a lot of reasons for
that uh bill gates famously said that we
uh we're short about two dozen great
innovations to get there
uh that's why we uh and my organization
has been arguing
for a long time we should be spending
about 100 billion dollars on
research and development into green
energy every year the world spends about
20 billion dollars right now so that's a
five-fold increase
that would help enormously because the
trick here is to make sure that we
actually get green energy be
so cheap that everyone will want to
switch
rather than right now as we have to do
twist everybody's arm
to get a little bit of reduction in co2
emissions
but let's not do the dumb stuff
and that is this proposal ending fossil
fuels in 20 years
is spectacularly wasteful way of helping
a little it'll likely fail
it will make us ignore the policies that
will fix climate when we're so focused
on getting all of our fossil fuels out
and get renewables in
we forget to invest in innovation we
forget to invest
in a carbon tax which we've seen
fail most places around the world if you
forget to focus
on adaptation but it also means that we
ignore the solutions
for most people around the world matter
a lot more the ones that matter much
more the ones that help much more
the ones that'll help much faster and
help
at a much lower cost like for instance
education nutrition
and health so the fundamental point here
that i'm trying to make
is simply to make us realize yes global
warming is a real problem
it's a moderate problem we should make
smart policies but we should not please
not make the policies that will make us
incredibly much worse off
and that will also fail and that will
make us forget
all the other issues that we really need
to focus on so thank you very much i'm
looking very much forward to a great
conversation with
you jeff and all the questions from the
audience
thank you bjorn uh we now go to the
rebuttal
part of the debate uh five minutes for
you jeff
uh to rebut take it away jeff
so um first i just wanted to say um
at the opening i i i enjoyed the
presentation bjorn you're you are
clearly a statistician
um you uh chart after chart after chart
lots of statistics
um so i i enjoyed that so um
i also want to say very quickly i i even
though i say we don't need to have
innovation i'm a big fan of
innovation i'm a big fan of r d i mean i
spent
years of my life the national science
foundation and first in the bush
administration then the obama
administration
um i clearly believe that lots more
research and innovation can only help so
so i want to get that out of the way i
also want to say that i
look i my organization helped launch the
climate leadership council which
advocates for a 40 carbon tax we've put
out the statements from hundreds of
economists i'd love to see a carbon tax
i just don't think it's politically
realistic i don't think it's clearly not
feasible in the united states
um and finally there's no question that
we're going to have to adapt i
i think that's obvious that we're going
to have to adapt so where this sort of
boils down to is
uh as i view this bjorn is arguing this
is a moderate problem maybe not so
big a problem i'm saying clearly it is a
big problem
it has interlocking with saw
impacts across the board on other things
but i will also see this i just want to
point you know my son runs a global
public health organization that is
working on the front lines with
with community health workers my wife is
a physical therapist my daughter's a
physician works in
in in medical poverty my son is a lawyer
who represents migrant workers there are
lots of big problems and so i just want
to just put that out there i'm not
saying there aren't other big problems
so what it boils down to is one
is climate change a bigger you know a
big problem as i'm arguing or a moderate
or non-existing problem as
bjorn's arguing or or and is there going
to be exorbitant costs
so let's go to the cost equation so uh
you know i know bjorn you're a big fan
of william northhouse his dice theory i
get it
he says the gdp costs are huge enormous
but there's another nobel prize-winning
economist for economic science joseph
stiglitz
he and nick stern had their own panel
and they
which was supported by the world bank
where he was the chief economist he says
that isn't true at all
climate goals can be achieved with a
moderate price well within the range of
what global
the global economy absorbs from variable
energy prices now i'll be the first one
to admit i'm not an economist
um i would let joseph stiglitz argue
that as opposed to me i'm a writer and a
journalist who interviews folks and and
and
you know pulls that away from that north
house also
in my opinion and others that i've
talked to severely underestimates the
damage from climate change
climate impacts as i think i've tried to
show and i've
written about in my book that are cited
by hundreds of studies
aren't limited to just a few outdoor
places so the impact that it's
somehow only going to be two three four
percent is not true
you know just look at things like
acidification rising sea levels
storm surges water scarcity in the
subtropics food insecurity
biodiversity changes that create
pandemics i'm not saying that climate
change causes these but they're clearly
interlocked with them that's a lot of
impact
across the board and so i think how we
how we
how we how we disaggregate this the
climate change pure climate change
impacts with
these whipsaw effects i think is
important to understand i'll also say
that climate change
fuels extreme events there there's lots
of attribution studies
studies in the scientific literature
that's now starting to show this
um and i'll also say in terms of gdp
laws just in one year alone in 2017
the united states lost one and a half
percent of its gdp
uh from these extreme events and again i
can you know just
anticipating where you're going to come
at this bjorn i'm not saying that
these hurricanes or these extreme events
are caused by climate change and that's
the sole reason for the property and
loss of life
but they're clearly interlocked and so
the question is
how much are they responsible for it i
think i think we can have a reasonable
debate about that
the arguments i would also that your
arguments they really don't take into
what's
known as tail risk and somebody i've
learned from hank paulson who is the
secretary of the treasury
his risky business report was issued out
of my own organization
hank also wrote an op-ed for the new
york times where he talks about this
tail risk
he calls it a a a climate risk bubble
again this is hank
who who who who laid out who helped save
the united states economy coming out of
a recession
so i think you would want to take it
seriously when a guy like hank paulson
a republican treasury secretary says
tail risk and climate risk bubbles are
real we need to pay
very close attention to it um that's
what i do so i i i take that and finally
i'll just say
um i don't think it's right for us to
ignore or discount the environmental so
societal impact of climate change on
future generations
so i'm uneasy with talking about but
costs now
um and benefits for for for generations
in the future um
that somehow we can incur costs now for
benefits in the g
in the future and i'll just say i know
this is a terrible analogy but i'll just
it's it's i'll just use it anyway
i have three kids my wife and i paid for
their college education
that's a cost right now for a future
benefit it's a pretty simple equation i
think that we can do that as a society
as well
thank you uh jeff uh five minutes uh for
you
uh bjorn take it away thank you so jeff
uh thank you very much
and i also enjoyed your uh presentation
a lot uh and i think you're absolutely
right that we should
you know really boil this conversation
down uh to the two questions of
is this a big problem uh i you somehow
mentioned that i was
almost suggesting that it's not a
problem all that's not what i'm saying
right but that it's a more moderate
problem
uh which i think uh uh the overwhelming
literature and certainly also the young
climate panel
tells us that it is uh but i think much
more importantly
so you were talking about is it going to
be an exorbitant cost
um i think it's important to recognize
that none of the policies that we've
done
so far have come out cheaper they've
come out much more expensively so the eu
2020 policy which is the best uh study
policy that we can now see how much
cost it was the eu said it would cost
0.5 percent of gdp
uh the uh the big climate models that
came out of the
stanford energy modeling forum uh showed
that it would cost about one percent of
gdp
uh but unfortunately the eu decided to
implement it in a rather foolish way
uh as politicians often like to do uh
which
ended up costing about two percent of
gdp
now it's important to recognize that
none of these
will bring the eu to the poor house and
so i think
your point is right in saying of course
we can do this
we can spend you know 16 of gdp and
remember
by 2050 and especially by 2100 we will
be much much richer
so again uh to go to your uh your
college analogy for your kids
uh clearly you want to leave your kids
with smart stuff uh and and
generationally one of the things that we
found is
one of the best ways to leave your kids
and future generations
is through knowledge and through of a
technology of
resources so basically make sure that
kids
are the next generation have lots of
resources
lots of knowledge that they will be able
to figure out the problems that will
come
in the next generations the next two
generations but
let's just make sure that we actually do
that
you gave your kids a college education
i'm pretty sure if you were the weird
dad who had decided to invest all of his
money in
i don't know model trains you you you
went first with a bad analogy so i can
just go on along with that uh you know
i'm pretty sure they'd be pretty annoyed
if you'd given them all your resources
and model trains and you'd be like all
excited about
the point is of course we should make
sure we leave our kids and future
generations
with really good stuff it's very hard to
know what is good stuff
in a hundred years uh you showed the uh
the uh mayday sorry for east
yeah uh from new york
remember you see switches very very
quickly
when there's an obvious benefit to
individuals
one of the big problems with climate
policy is that there's no obvious
individual benefit if we really get the
climate
revolution right sorry if we get the
energy of revolution right
you will get exactly the same out of
your plugs as you used to get namely
stable cheap
electric power at the very best it'll
just feel like nothing changed
at worst of course it will feel like oh
my god i only get it when the wind is
blowing or the sun is shining which i
think nobody really wants
so the point here is it's a very
different technology transition
it's only one that is driven by cost
there is no other great thing
you wanted a car rather than a horse
because it was
cheaper it was better in so many
different ways you want it to switch to
google because it was so much better
than using the library
you want it to switch to a cell phone
because it was so much better
than waiting at a wide phone and all
these other things
most innovations have been great because
they changed something
we're actually talking about making an
innovation that will change
nothing and that's why this is going to
be about cost
and i think we can't really ignore the
fact
that all of these studies so the u.n
climate panel very clearly tells us
that all of these impacts will have
costs
yes we'll get uh jobs but you get jobs
no matter what you do
the point is you get jobs when you have
someone doing
productive stuff but you don't get
much welfare if you do unproductive
stuff thank you very much
so the sorry did you say one minute well
yes yes yeah yes
yes good great so fundamentally
you you're right we're basically down to
is this the end of the world
and i understand why a lot of people
will present as the end of world both
it's a much easier and much more nicer
story to tell
it also makes it much easier to say
we've got to spend anything you know
obviously if this was an asteroid
hurtling towards earth
we should spend everything we should
send you know bruce willis up there and
fix it
uh and that only works for people of the
older generation right but the
but the point is it is not such a thing
it is a problem
and unfortunately your solution the
20-year
uh solution of of going entirely fossil
free
is not only i think absolutely
unrealistic
but if we try to do it be phenomenally
expensive and there's no good reason to
believe that that is not exactly what
that will happen
thank you thank you bjorn all right we
now go to the
q and a portion of the evening we have
questions that came in from the audience
and the first rule of
q a is that uh any uh either of the
debaters at any time
have uh the prerogative to ask the other
a question
and i'll begin by asking if you want to
exercise the prerogative now or wait for
questions
uh jeff would you like to pose a
question to bjorn at this moment
or waive the opportunity until later um
yeah i have a couple of questions i've
asked i like to ask bjorn
do i just go one or two okay the first
is that's the first and then we'll get
to the second going
okay first bjorn you talk about but the
the the you know about that
if if if the rich world which we're
talking about the eu
and the united states and several others
if they act
it's still not going to have enough of
an impact well of course that's true
i mean it you know but that's not what
we're talking about the paris climate
agreement
was every country in the world china has
committed
to to doing things if if china alone
acts that's 17
of the problem so and india is all a
bigger so i so my question is
is that fair to just focus on if the
rich world acts
and the rest of the world doesn't is
that is that a fair way to address
impacts yeah yeah and and it's a good
question
uh lor i think it's worthwhile because
we have this conversation in the rich
world
it mostly is the rich world conversation
it mostly is in the rich world
there where there's conversation about
actually going actively
uh net zero by 2050. you're right that
china i think
mostly strategically uh come out and
said that they want to peak in 2030 and
that they want to
go carbon neutral in 2060 if you read
their document they also promise that
they'll go democratic by 2050.
so i think it gives us a sense of what
we can realistically expect
uh i think it depends a lot on what will
happen
in in the far future uh if we manage to
innovate
the prices of green energy down below
fossil fuels
and we also have a way to make sure that
that just doesn't work
when the sun is shining or the wind is
blowing which either mean batteries
it means much better biomass right now
biomass i think is a terrible choice
but it could become a really good choice
uh or nuclear power or
or a fusion there are many other ways
that we can imagine this but if some of
these things come true
of course everybody's gonna jump on the
on the bandwagon
you mentioned for instance electric cars
uh i think
many people are gonna switch to electric
cars over the next 10 years
uh we should also just have a sense of
proportion of what that's going to do
so the international energy agency
estimates that if we actually
successfully managed to get
to uh 360 million uh electric cars about
a third
uh by 2030 it will reduce
carbon emissions by about one percent
this is a very small part of the
solution and it's the easy one
and it's not going to solve
transportation needs in general
it's going to solve a rather niche
problem it's great thing
i i love the fact that it's happening i
hate the fact that we're right now
spending ten
thousand dollars in subsidies in each
electric car
uh we should not be doing that uh well
the u.s is spending what seven
seven thousand five hundred in
california in california you also give a
top-up
so i think it becomes ten thousand right
many other countries they're spending
about you know somewhere between
six and ten thousand dollars that's a
terrible idea
but again innovations can come and you
know
the electric car for some parts is going
to be a great innovation
and great that'll happen but this only
shows that's the kind of solution that
we need in a lot of different areas
sorry i think i meandered a little bit
away from here
yeah okay i'll hold you a second
question jeff i want to i want to put
the ball back in uh
jeff's into bjorn's court uh do you have
a question for jeff if you want to wave
it
i i think it's much more fun to hear the
audience questions i hope we might be
able to get back to
questions to each other but i think we
want to get others in we'll begin to
audience questions but jeff has the
second question for you
i do it yeah and i actually think it's
it's just in line with what what you
were just talking about bjorn
so i very quickly a bit of a backdrop so
when uh the the u.s economy was
collapsing i was at the national science
foundation i was their chief lobbyist
and their chief public affairs official
it was my job to try to to pull money
from the recovery act
so i was able to successfully lobby for
three billion dollars for the national
science foundation
to fund you know spectacular r d well
one of the biggest bets
was on battery storage a billion dollar
bet on battery storage this was back in
2009
so i think i would encourage you to sort
of update the way you think about this
because the truth is that big bet
in r d which you're a fan of way back
then
is now paying dividends you now see this
this question of when the sun is shining
or whatever
that's no longer really an issue anymore
thanks to r d
that has really accelerated along with
other things like microgrids
storage solutions and other things so my
question to you is
if that were solved if r d were to solve
this problem
would you worry so much about about
solar and wind
uh no uh but you're unfortunately
not very i'm i'm very happy you got a
billion dollars for batteries
uh but i think you uh you you're
entirely missing the scale of a problem
i'm sure you
you actually know this uh but right now
there's batteries enough
in the whole of the us to cover 14
seconds of u.s
electricity consumption average u.s
electricity consumption
so no we're nowhere near being able to
fix this
and and the real reason i think a lot of
people fail to get this
um the real reason why solar and wind
cannot actually
uh uphold and end up making the the grid
much more expensive is
because all solar especially comes at
the same time
this is also true but slightly less uh
uh true for
for win but if you look at all solar it
all comes around midday
that's great for the first couple
percent of energy because typically in
most countries
uh noon is about the the the peak time
so it actually eats into the peak time
which is some of the most expensive
production of electricity
so it actually helps a country but what
very quickly happens
is that it starts eating into the
revenue of all the other producers
you end up with an enormous glut of
electricity
so when you when you hear countries for
instance going uh
you know typically for the first for the
first time oh we've just produced a
hundred percent of
electricity of uh for a country what you
never hear is
and the price went negative uh it's
actually worth
nothing because you can't sell this at
any other time
so what you end up with is you're
selling a lot of electricity at very low
cost
and then you have to get the rest of the
cost covered
for the non-solar and non-wind by
much much higher cost electricity that's
produced elsewhere
which is why you end up seeing all these
effects and you've seen that much more
in europe than you have in the u.s
because europe just has much more uh
renewable power and also done it
probably but
worse i i would say but mostly simply
because
you can't have a lot of solar or a lot
of wind
without much much more battery so when
you're talking about batteries
they're trivial and they will still be
trivial by 2040.
now if we can get much more uh battery
so
the ia has done so the international
energy agency has done a big study
uh especially on india because india has
some of the best
solar not surprisingly there right uh
you know the at the equator
uh and they could actually have a
situation where they'll have
so much battery that they will start not
putting up new coal fired power plants
after 2030. that'd be wonderful it cut a
full percent
of emissions uh towards 2040
but it's not going to solve everything
it's going to solve a bit
a bit part and yes we should be spending
a lot more money on this
uh but we need to get a sense of of
of size of this issue and you know just
to give you uh
just sorry wrap this up um if you look
at solar
once you have 15 percent of solar uh for
instance in california
the price drops by two-thirds uh once
you have about 13
30 percent of wind the price drops more
than 50 percent
which is why when people tell you it's
uh
competitive it's only competitive if you
don't think about the fact that you have
lots of others
uh already running so yes we should have
a little bit of solar and wind
but once you start having a lot of solar
and wind you're basically disrupting the
whole energy system
that's why you end up with much higher
cost and without much much more storage
we're talking about storage
that would run into months uh which is
right now and certainly in the next
decades
almost um fantastical to imagine that
that would happen even if
prices drop dramatically as we're hoping
they will and we're hoping that r d will
make him drop even more
even faster thank you bjorn uh and uh
so let's uh turn to a couple of uh
audience questions
uh uh there's a certified uh symmetrical
questions for both of you
uh let's start with you born uh the
challenge is this
you were speaking in terms of dollars in
gdp
and the impression for the audience is
jeff is speaking in terms of human lives
that human lives are being threatened
even as we speak
by all the things that he listed uh the
himalayas
uh acidification all of that and so
could you change your metric for the
moment and say what's
what what's it what's it gonna save in
terms of human life
to do what jeff proposes and august what
might it cost in human life to do what
just
jeff proposes yes uh there's uh because
we only had 17 and a half minutes i've
cut
back a lot of slides i'd love to show so
now i'm just gonna have to tell you
and you have to take me on the i'll i'll
tweet this afterwards
uh so if you look at the last hundred
years uh the number of people have died
from climate-related sas floods droughts
uh uh storms uh extreme temperatures uh
it's dropped precipitously it's actually
drop is that the right word
precipitously
yeah good thank you sometimes i worry
that that meant precipitation
anyway so uh so it's dropped 95 percent
and since we've at the same uh 100 years
quadruple
global population the individual risk of
dying from climate-related disasters has
dropped by 99
so uh i actually showed you graphs of
human life i showed you one of the
biggest
uh uh uh environmental problems that
kill the most humans
clearly many many other problems
especially indoor outdoor
air pollution and and water and
sanitation kills many more people
than global warming does but also it's
very likely that
things that jeff worries about that
we're going to uh more
extreme storms uh so just to give you a
sense of that the u.n
estimate will probably see fewer storms
but we'll see more
violent storms and violent storms are
worse
than fewer of them so overall we'll have
bigger impacts
so jeff is right that this is going to
be a bigger problem but it'll actually
kill
many fewer people because we'll get much
richer and we'll be better able to adapt
so the real answer here is to say this
is the world
where we used to see about half a
million people die from climate-related
disasters today we see about 20
000 people die globally from
climate-related disasters
in the future we'll probably see many
fewer we'll maybe see
say 5 000 but had we not had global
warming or had we have
jeff's projection of a policy institute
we might see four thousand or three
thousand people and honestly i'm making
up these numbers because we don't have
data because they're so small
but that order of magnitude we'd save a
few thousand people
but the cost would come in terms of
especially poor people but that's both
poor people in rich countries and poor
people in poor countries
who would have less access to more
expensive and less reliable energy
that would have much greater health care
costs
very clearly it has cost when you both
have uh heating and cooling which is one
of the
big killers of of humans around the
world we estimate
probably in the order of 10 percent of
all deaths are due to heat and cold
deaths most of them are cold deaths
actually
and we know that when people have to pay
more
to heat their homes they heat them worse
and so more people will die
it is very likely and i can't give you
the exact numbers but it's very
likely that orders of magnitude so 10
100 maybe even a thousand times more
people would die
from these policies than would be saved
from them
from not having uh climate related
disasters jeff could you comment on uh
response
so i i will say this
the problem here is that what we're
talking about is what's happened in the
past versus what might happen in the
very near future
again the reason why i wrote the book uh
whether
folks want to agree with it or not i
hope they lose you know take a look at
it
check out the citations is that i'm
arguing
that these impacts are here now right
now not
50 years from now because one of the big
arguments that you hear now for those
who are arguing for the status quo is
let's just wait and see how bad it gets
um and which the truth is if these
if there is a tail risk and if these as
i believe are
going to be significant costs to society
to human life
across the board um we can't wait 50
years to see how bad it's going to get
it's going to be significantly much
worse 50 years from now so that's why
acting now is important so i i believe
it's a bit of a red herring to talk
about well things haven't happened in
the past
you know it's true nobody's migrated
from bangladesh
because bangladesh is not underwater so
there are no climate
uh related problems uh but if bangladesh
goes underwater and they have to go
somewhere then there are going to be all
sorts of impacts
yemen's another great example i really
dug into yemen
as a very perfect example of the climate
scientists said because it's in the
subtropics because we're seeing climate
impacts now
that water scarcity is an issue right
now it's only going to get worse in the
very very near future it's going to drop
these wells that's exactly what happened
in yemen and the warlords took control
after 14 of the 16
aquifers went dry took control of the
remaining two created this internal
strife
it led to a great deal of loss of human
life
and a great deal of suffering in yemen
you can see this play out across the
board the same thing is happening in the
cell you can make a very
clear case that because the climate
impacts are happening right now
again not a hundred percent you know
responsible
but this whip saw uh interlocking uh
impacts is driving things even like the
creation of terrorism in some of these
countries
so there is a great deal of impact on
human life but
my main response is that just looking
backwards
um to climate impacts that that aren't
yet happening
is is a is an unfair comparison to
what's going to happen this water
already what's happening now but is
going to happen in the very near future
not 50 years from now
can i just say something very very
quickly all right go ahead
sorry so just jeff if you're saying this
is happening right now
we have the data we know that there used
to be half a million people dying from
climate related disasters 100 years ago
now there's 20 000 people dying from
climate-related disasters
this is not something we can have an
opinion on this is simply true
that the risk has reduced 99 and it's
kept reducing since the 1980s as well
so look there's just you know if you're
going to say it's right now
you're just wrong now you can say that
in the near future something bad is
going to happen and that the past is not
a good
example for for the future and you know
that that's a fair argument but i think
the models very clearly tell us
that that's not going to happen either
you want to respond jeff or do you want
to wait for the next question well
that's fine i mean i uh i'm not wrong
but that there are impacts right now
i mean that's those are nice statistics
you've thrown out there but clearly
um we see climate impacts right now i
mean i could go i'll just i'll just give
you one example
i mean the fact that half of all species
are experiencing local extinctions
that is as big a canary in a coleman as
you're going to see
and i interviewed terry root for my book
who is the preeminent biodiversity
expert in the country
she's beside herself that nobody quite
understands what is happening to species
on earth
the human species is just one of
hundreds of thousands of species but the
fact that we're seeing
that occur right now means something
that is a
big statistic not a small one that is a
very large statistic
so to say that i'm wrong that impacts
are happening now i would argue
that's you know that's not correct they
are happening now and every it's
that's why that's why um the thousands
of climate scientists who look you know
talk about
you know multiple levels to describe the
climate
uh fingerprint and the climate impacts
there that they've
they've they've anticipated and now
they're seeing it
question for uh bjorn uh
jeff mentioned uh another nobel prize
winner joseph stiglitz
who takes a different position on
costs and benefits of jeff's proposals
from the other nobel president you
mentioned
could you respond to jeff's point
about the alternative measures that
joseph stiglitz has associated
himself with beyond yeah something uh
two points first of all uh joe sticklitz
got his nobel prize
in the communication of uh information
in in markets like youth uh cars
uh he did great work in that he's not a
climate economist nobody
nordhouse got his economics price in
climate economics uh i don't know all of
joe sticklet's work but i do know the uh
the uh the work that
jeff uh mentioned uh and uh
he did that work together with nicholas
stern what they showed was
and i think jeff also correctly mention
it was
that a carbon price can actually
manage a transition to a lower carbon
economy
at a reasonable price that's absolutely
true there's no one who would
deny that you can do this at a
reasonable price especially if you get
to
decide yourself what is reasonable uh
but
clearly you can have a reasonable
transition
so you know if you go for the 80 below
to
1990 levels as the eu did uh you can
probably do it for five percent
that's that's doable that's reasonable
uh i think a lot of people would still
think it's way too expensive and as i
pointed out
i think most voters are going to say no
to that way before that happens
but they did not show that this was a
good investment of money
and i think it goes to the whole point
of of jeff's uh
jeff's argument uh i think jeff slightly
skewed or
sort of slid away from his answer and
start talking about a lot of other
species
i was simply making the point about we
have good statistics for humans
and you're saying it has impacts on
humans right now and it doesn't
in in those statistics uh but but but
but the
but the main point here remains
that the question is what would have
happened
for instance in yemen and other places
had we made
an enormous climate policy
back in say 1980 or 1990 1992 when
when we first promised had the whole
world stopped using climate
uh uh uh uh fossil fuels what would have
happened
well very little we know it would have
had very very tiny impact on the
temperatures
for yemen and the 2010s it would however
have made every country in the world
much much poorer
including of course making many hundreds
of millions of people
keeping them in poverty so the real
question here is not
would i love to be able to snap my
fingers and make climate change go away
yes i would love that
because yes jeff is right climate change
is a problem
the real question is of course outside
this sort of uh
wishful thinking is we have to pay a
price
for a climate policy to get a benefit
and the question is
how big is the cost how big is the
benefit and joe sticklitz and nicholas
stern
did not do that uh calculation and i
don't
i don't i'm not very surprised they
didn't do it because they know what the
answer is
there's been lots of people doing lots
of those estimates uh over the last
couple years
sorry over the last couple of decades
and they've all found the same thing we
should do some
but not a lot uh do you want to respond
uh to uh
uh john bjorn's answer jeff well
no i don't think so because i i i
i wouldn't presume to answer for joe
stiglitz i mean i think he
defends himself quite well i think he's
actually written uh
about some of this about your book bjorn
in the new york times so i think he
answers
this for himself uh and i've
characterized it somewhat here here in
this discussion
uh question for jeff then uh the the
audience
is characterizing your argument jeff
as a little bit ambivalent as to whether
you
think that uh that conversion from
fossil fuels to clean energy is
so efficient that it's going to happen
anyway
versus the opposite idea
that it might not happen anyway but
policy makers have got to make it happen
force it to happen because unless they
force it to happen
it won't happen so could you clarify
your position with respect to those
two different approaches yeah i will and
i'll and i'll say
it's a that's a really good question i i
believe this it will be a messy
transition
and i'm going to use the transition on
the internet as a good example
and and and i think this will be i i
hope this will be helpful for the
audience
uh again i worked at the national
science foundation when
there was a thing called the world wide
web long before anybody knew what it was
uh the pentagon was running super
computers they
they handed off things called pops they
handed off
things you know uh you know that that
could create this
interconnected thing uh you know the
worldwide web long before there was the
internet
well the national science foundation
placed a big bet they bet a
big part of their budget to connect
every university
in the united states and then on the
planet to connect with these plots to
basically
build the architecture of the internet
so there was a big bet that was a policy
that was a political decision by
congress
actually al gore was involved in that he
was the reauthorized national
science foundation specifically to build
that architecture
so there is there are policy drivers
there are political drivers
there are financial incentives there are
public incentives
and i believe the same thing is going to
happen here uh
it's true as bjorn has noted i i did
focus very heavily on
where private financial groups are going
i didn't focus as much
on public drivers like the paris climate
agreement like nationally determined
carbon dioxide levels for for for
companies
you know the ndc is under the paris
climate agreement i didn't focus on the
public side of the equation
there's going to have to be both the
reason why i thought i wanted to focus
on the private sector side of the
equation is because
i really believe you're seeing a very
clear signal right now
from financial analysis analysts who see
both climate risk and opportunity
from big business ceos who are clearly i
mean if you look at the big tech
companies
they're clearly trying to get they're
competing with each other to get to
100 renewable energy in their supply
chains
and you know by 2030. they're doing that
for a reason they're under pressure
both from the public side and the
private side so i think ambivalence
probably the wrong word to describe what
i'm
trying to articulate i'm focusing on the
private sector i'm focusing on
private uh financial analysis but i do
believe
absolutely there may there has to be a
public component to it
it can be regulatory it can be political
it can be policy oriented
um and honestly it's probably going to
be a bit
messy just like the transition to the
internet was a big
a bit messy go back to what i said about
the new york times
had an opportunity once upon a time
early on to buy 25 percent of google
their answer was
google what's the internet that's not a
that's not going to compete against me
um and so so they said no i think the
same thing is going on right now
some are placing big bets on a future
that i believe is going to be here
much sooner than people realize jordan
you want to comment on jeff's response
so um well i mean the private sector is
mostly in
uh on this because it is pr you
mentioned that
most the big tech companies want to go
to 100 by 2030.
well that's because they mostly emit
fairly little co2
it's easy to do when you have little uh
uh emissions
uh sky and europe was the first uh uh
big corporation in europe to go carbon
neutral
that's because they basically just have
a few pcs that they had to offset
so it's very very easy when you're small
companies most of these private
companies do it because it's profitable
for them
because they're going to get lots and
lots of money that's going to be handed
out by a lot of different programs
to a lot of different policies but let's
not for one
second presuppose that that's going to
fix
global warming there global warming is
at
heart a public problem it's a problem
where putting out co2
creates problems that have nothing to do
with me it has everything to do with
everyone else
which is why you need public regulation
for it that's also why
unless you get public regulation you're
never going to attack very much of the
problem
so i think in some way it's it's a
little disturbing if
jeff if you if you've almost entirely
focused on the private bit
because this is going to be about all of
us this is about the paris agreement
and how we're going to do both as
individual nations and certainly as
as a global community and that's where
our in
our our experience has been we've
constantly been promising stuff and not
living up to it
uh we promised in rio in 1992 didn't
live up to it
in kyoto most didn't live up to the only
reason
why some did was because of the
financial crisis
uh and now we promised in paris and even
if everybody does what they promise
it will have a minimal impact on
temperatures so we're still
far far away from what we need to do and
that's why i'm arguing that the
uh that the studies clearly show this is
going to be very very expensive
all right we have a a time for like one
final question i guess lob to you bjorn
uh uh jeff has mentioned a few times
uh the idea of tail risk and your
instance interpreting that to mean that
there's some you know one in a thousand
chance likely or something like that
of a true disaster do you acknowledge
that
risk and if so what do you propose doing
about it
yes so uh it's actually a good argument
and i think it is the best argument for
making uh bigger investments so nordhaus
and many others have looked at this
and it does increase the amount of
investment that we should put
in and climate policy uh one of the
things that i try to work with my
organization
uh since jeff has been uh flaunting his
book i guess i should also just mention
that i have a new book out
uh and you should take a look at that uh
but but what i mostly actually do
uh is is focusing on on
looking across all the different areas
so with my think tank the copenhagen
consensus
uh we look at all the different
investments that you can do in the world
so should you be investing in nutrition
or an education or in health care
or in global warming or in uh or in air
pollution and
gender equality and all these other
challenges that the world faces
and i think one of the problems that we
have when we talk about existential risk
is
if you look out till 2100 almost
every policy that you can imagine
can have a potential existential risk
all you need is to say
there's a non-zero risk of if we choose
this deci
if we go down this route it'll open up
you know say
if we don't tackle hiv in sub-saharan
africa it's gonna make some african
countries collapse you're gonna get
terrorism throw in bio uh uh terrorism
throwing you know the ability to make
viruses
and wham bam you have the death of
everyone before 2100.
again it's not uh given it may even be a
very very small risk
but it's a non-zero risk and so we
should be spending more money here
the problem with the argument of tail
risk
is if everything has tail risk you
really have to ask
how do we handle these different issues
and i like to just uh
very briefly say we we actually have a
good estimate
uh because back in the late 1980s early
1990s
uh we started realizing that you know
asteroids could hit the earth
we we've always known but you know
people started realizing we could
actually figure that out
and the us congress asked nasa to find
90 of all these uh asteroids that could
hit earth
nasa had also provided a budget for
finding 99
of them but congress felt that that was
too costly
so there we have it you actually have a
very clear estimate of how much we're
willing to spend extra on safeguarding
us against the next
nine percent of tail risk and the answer
is not very much
and i think that's also what we see
generally across history
we have tail risks everywhere we look we
cannot afford
to worry about each and every one of
them of course every single participant
who's just arguing for their particular
issue will say tail risk give me more
money
but overall we have to recognize that
their tail risks
everywhere not just in global warming
jeff like
we we are out of time for the q a please
if you want to respond to what do i just
said roll that into your
final summation we'll have seven and
half minutes for that
you have to go to that part of it so uh
jeff uh for the final
summation would you take it away great
you know i'll just say that was uh that
was uh
i enjoyed listening to that discussion
about tail risk so um
it's it tail rescues was just one of
those very diff i mean insurance
companies take a look at tail risk
you know financial analysts who have to
manage vast sums of money look at tail
risk
so um it's certainly a valid question i
so let me just try to sum up this way
if i can i don't have a prepare i just
want to sort of go through sort of where
we've had the discussion first
i would argue that the paris climate
agreement because my organization we
were there we were there every single
day we
we held like 24 press conferences over a
12-day period in paris the paris climate
agreement was a breakthrough moment for
the world
rio copenhagen all the kyoto all those
things that bjorn talks about
it's true they didn't get a whole lot
done there's a lot of talk
that was not the case for the paris
climate agreement the paris climate
agreement changed everything when you
have every single country in the world
rich and poor
um coming together saying we are going
to take this issue seriously we're going
to get this done we're going to figure
out a way
between public and private sector that
was a big deal so i
so that's why things have changed
and i will say in the united states it's
interesting bjorn talks about
there isn't this public will to deal
with this that's not the case in the
united states
climate change for the democratic party
for democratic voters in the united
states is
it is now their top issue you saw it
very clearly we had we had climate
change questions
for both presidential debates and the
vice presidential debate
it was the one issue that dominated
across all three
it is a very big deal in the united
states as an issue
it's at the bottom of the list for the
republican party for
multiple reasons and this is from
somebody i worked in a republican
administration
i was dan quayle's communications
director in a republican white house
i was a republican political appointed
the fda a science-based agency
i also worked at the national science
foundation in a republican
administration
um and it has always bothered me
immensely that the republican party
has not dealt with this issue from a
science basis so that continues to
bother me but i will tell you
it is absolutely a paramount concern in
the united states
there is massive public support for
clean renewable energy and for a
transition
whether we want to argue about whether
it's going to take 20 years 40 years 50
years 60 years
the public would like to see it they'd
like to see jobs
as many as possible that's why i
mentioned this rewiring america
study that showed quite clearly there
are millions of new jobs waiting to
happen
um it's because there is a pent-up
demand for this
um i i would say and i would say at
least in the united states and and it
could be around the world
it's a bipartisan approach people want
to see this transition
and they'd actually like to see it
sooner rather than later it's one of the
reasons i would argue that virtually
every analyst
says that clean energy a clean energy
economy
is the next big thing um if if you look
i mean most people think
that the global economy may not um
growth thank you may not see dramatic
growth um
uh absent this clean energy revolution
so
yes i know i'm focusing on the private
sector i'm happy to talk about the
public sector which i will in just a
second
but but why not bet on that future why
not i mean
just as some people said let's bet on a
technology revolution in a technology
driven global economy
why not bet on this clean energy uh
revolution as well
and on the corporate sector yes i i hear
you bjorn when you say
they look like it's it's done for public
relations purposes
it may be done because they don't have
necessarily an outside footprint
but i will say this when virtually every
fortune
1000 ceo gets in the game and just puts
their
company's reputation behind it at some
point and i hope
certainly much sooner than later those
commitments
by those corporate leaders translate
into real meaningful action across the
board when you see facebook and google
and amazon
and microsoft and unilever and
salesforce
competing to get to 20 30 targets
they could just as easily provide net
zero by 2050 targets
they're not doing that they're saying
it'll be by 2030.
i would argue that's going to translate
into a global
economic opportunity probably within a
decade
then on the public sector side and i can
speak most of the united states because
i have a great deal of experience in the
political sector
i'll predict right now in 2021 i guess
we'll see what happens with the
elections in in
two weeks but i believe there's going to
be a
massive public sector approach to
dealing with this issue
it could come in the form it could come
in one of three forms it could come in
the form of
a multi-trillion dollar economic
recovery package
that that creates conservation cores and
and and rebuilds things and puts
together infrastructure
but also infrastructure on the financial
side of the equation
that's a public sector driver i believe
you'll see um the first
serious effort for a big climate uh bill
i just interviewed the chairman of the
house select committee and climate i've
talked to
senate democrats um they're prepared to
move on the public sector side of the
equation finally
after years of not being able to do so
and i think there also is going to be
across the administration if it
if joe biden does win the election
there's a very good chance that across
every single public sector aspect of the
federal government they're going to do
something
both on the climate emission side of the
equation but also on the
clean energy revolution side of the
equation
um i also wanted to talk very briefly
and then close with this
that um we talked earlier in this
discussion about rich versus poor action
among rich versus poor
and it's true that the rich countries
they can't solve this problem
yemen couldn't solve the problem if had
they taken and i think that's a bit of a
red herring to talk about if
if you saw you know yemen couldn't solve
the climate problem but if the world
solves the climate problem
if water scarcity was not an issue in
yemen then there's a then there's
every chance that you don't see some of
those societal problems there
that's the point here that this is a
global public comments problem
that the global economy needs to respond
to it the countries and the leaders and
the business leaders need to respond to
it
and i do believe it yes it's in china's
best interest because they don't want
they lost the technology race they do
not intend to lose lose the clean energy
race
i can guarantee you that that's part of
what's driving them and if china acts
and they act meaningfully that will have
an impact likewise in india
i i've talked to the leadership of the
rockefeller foundation that's that's
that's betting on a microgrid solution
that will help um the energy poor in
india i think i
i i believe india is going to get there
they would love to see
um a clean energy a cheap clean energy
solution because they
that's that's what's going to get to
those 3 400 million people who don't
have power right now
they would love to see that and i
actually genuinely believe they will
they will they will get there and that
will help with that problem and then
i'll just close with this i i i will i
what i've been arguing here is that we
have public will
we have financial interest we have
um human interest finally after so many
years of looking at
raw statistics and questions about
policy
we're starting to see human beings
interested in this and i'll just leave
you with one
discussion this is the united states
there are there are victims in 20 states
that have banded together called higher
ground who have
who have lost their homes or lost
property from flooding
that's driven by climate change um and
we
we could talk about the science behind
this and the climate science behind it
and so i'm just going to put it out
there as a given climate change is is
is is now intersecting with this and so
you have human interest people
you see people in houston who are
worried about the flooding that swept
through the city you're seeing
wildfires and we can you know this is a
climate science uh
question but you know wildfires are
bigger and hotter um
and it's one of the reasons why it's
it's becoming very hard to ensure things
in california
you're seeing human interest in this
story so the combination of all of those
things
uh leaves me convinced that the world
thanks to the paris climate agreement
and others
is going to act so thank you and thank
you for for the opportunity to
hold this discussion thank you jeff okay
and uh
bjorn seven and a half minutes for
rebuttal for summer excuse me
well yes i think it's more going to be a
summary so uh yes jeff thank you very
much for this
conversation uh i i think the way that
we've been framed this
is very much uh sort of leading up to
whether you should vote yes or no
uh to this proposition uh so so i i
think we need to get a sense
again of proportion so uh jeff is very
upbeat uh and and uh you know i was
i was at paris as well i didn't hold as
many press conferences as you did
clearly
but i think we also got to be honest and
say
yes countries made a lot of noise there
was a lot of reporting there
but even if all countries live up to all
of their promises
it'll have a miniscule impact on
temperatures
even 80 years from now now if they
kept those promises and kept them for
the rest of their century
it would reduce temperatures by 0.3
degrees
fahrenheit that's very little and of
course
no major partner is actually poised
to keep their current promises let alone
the bigger promises that they're
now going to be rattling off climate
policy has
constantly been about making grand
promises
and then not keeping them and i question
whether that's the best way to leave our
kids
uh you know so instead of giving them a
college education as you were talking
about
we'll just promise them stuff and not
give it to them i think that's probably
one of the worst ways
that we can deal with the climate
problem or indeed any other problem
and so it gets back to saying is the
right way
to do this is that to promise not just
what we've already
done and is not keeping not just more
than what we've already promised but an
absurd amount namely let's go carbon
neutral
in 20 years something that we know is
not going to happen something we know is
going to be phenomenally costly
something we know is going to be much
much costlier
than the benefit of the drive plus at
the same time
it will take away attention from all the
things that will help
both with climate so adaptation carbon
tax and
certainly a lot of innovation and also
all the other issues
in the world so jeff also talks about
there's
massive support and yes you're right if
you ask people very
sort of shallowly do you want us to do
something about climate change they'll
say yes
if you ask them is this a really big
crisis they'll say yes it is a really
big crisis
they'll also say lots of other things
are big crisis crises
uh but if you then ask them are you
willing to pay for it
most people are only willing to pay a
couple hundred bucks for this as i
mentioned the
uh the washington post twenty four
dollars but you can get others uh you
know surveys that'll show that people
are willing to pay a couple hundred
dollars for it
right if you're then proposing the sorry
five minutes to go yeah
yeah five minutes yeah five minutes okay
good if you're then proposing
to people that you're gonna pay fifteen
hundred dollars
per year per person which is just the
you know the biden
uh proposal the trillion dollars of his
2 trillion
over 4 years uh and that's just a simple
math you're going to get people upset
people are not willing to spend that
much more money
you're saying that it'll generate more
jobs that'll generate more
opportunity but the reality is of course
if you are
getting and you know i'm just using the
official statistics
if you can get solar energy and
employ 39 people from solar energy for
every time you can employ
one person with gas you got to realize
that that's not a great thing that means
38 people are working
not on something else not on educating
your kids
not on taking care of your kids in
kindergarten or taking care of your
elderly or making better health care
or making better infrastructure and all
the other things that we also need
people for
using people to make incredibly
unproductive work is not a great idea
uh the if the famous skit is you know
when uh when you're in
in china and they're working uh just
digging uh digging with
shovels uh when when you when people
claim well that generate more jobs
then the obvious answer is well why
don't they just use teaspoons
if that's what you're trying to do but
of course the reality is
we're actually trying to make people
more productive so that we have
better opportunities so again when you
say that clean energy could be the new
thing in the 21st century
i think this is fundamentally wrong and
for a very simple reason we alluded to
that before
if you get the clean energy revolution
just right
nobody's going to be able to tell the
difference because you'll just get
clean power now out of your socket
before when you've
before got not clean energy out of your
socket
but it'll feel the exact same way
there's no way to get people excited
about this
google provided new uh opportunities all
technologies in the past have provided
new opportunities the only thing that
will drive this
is either a lot of money spent on
political
uh hold or that we get innovations that
just simply makes it
cheaper than fossil fuels i argue that
we should be focusing on making it
cheaper because that's the only
way that we're going to succeed in
getting the clean energy revolution but
we should not
allow ourselves to believe that this is
going to be easy and certainly not that
this is going to be
cheap and so that comes back to saying
we can have this conversation and you
rightly say this is a big issue
and and the u.s and it's also a big
issue in europe but the issue here
is how do we get people along with us to
actually accept that we're gonna be
spending
you know five or ten percent of gdp i
don't think you can do that
and i think that's why we need to
recognize instead of trying to
essentially curt with the yellow vest as
we saw in france when
uh when macron imposed a carbon tax
that's equivalent to 13 cents in the
gallon
of gasoline and you basically get the
country rioting for half a year
we need to find a way that allows us to
solve global warming
within the budget frame of what most
people say they're willing to pay
not by making trillion dollar deals that
will not be sustainable
in the long run and quite frankly if
corona has taught us anything it is
that we've pretty much run out of money
now we're not going to be able to also
support a huge and subsidy hungry
uh green energy reform so
uh you you talk about that we have
public will we have private will we have
human interest
well we have human interest as long as
it doesn't cost very much we have
private will as long as we get lots of
money from
the public and the public will i think
thank you
the public will is really just a
question
how much money are we willing to spend
i would argue we can spend a little and
we should spend it smartly i think jeff
and i'm sorry
i'm now going to characterize you
especially because you can't come back
at me
but i think jeff's proposal is basically
say let's spend lots and lots of money
badly on not fixing this problem very
well
and that's why i'm arguing we should
really
say no to this proposition it doesn't
mean say no to climate policy
it means let's say yes to smart climate
policy
unlike just saying let's all go carbon
neutral in 20 years which is just not
going to happen
is going to be phenomenally costly and
unfortunately going to
derail our conversations about real
impacts for climate
and all the other things that we also
need to tackle but again
thank you very much jeff it was i think
it was a great conversation i'm sorry
it's a slightly
sort of uh this confrontorial uh
conversation at the same time thanks for
your apology bjorn and uh thanks uh for
your contribution
to what is a clash of views it's not an
attack
on individuals it's not you guys have
been uh
marvelously polite to each other which
is quite appropriate no ad hominems
you disagree with each other and that's
what the audience wanted to hear
the the clash of views between you and i
commend you jeff and i commend you
bjorn on meeting that challenge both
the resolution of course reads to combat
climate change
the world's leaders must make it their
highest priority to completely replace
the burning of fossil fuels within the
next 20 years
uh well all right uh jeff you began with
13.33 percent of the of the vote
for yes the svo got 13.33
and you held at 13.33
so you kept your position but you didn't
add uh bjorn began with 60
of the vote went up to 86.67
for a gain of 26 points uh bjorn it
looks as though you win the tootsie roll
and uh so congratulations to you born
thank you very much
jeff and uh jeff i want to tell you
bjorn
english is not bjorn's first language so
he was at a little bit of a disadvantage
but he did very well in english jeff you
did as well
thank you to you both and uh and good
night to all
thanks very much good night thank you
very much and thanks jeff you
your english is really good jeff
that word you stumbled on beyond if you
fall off a precipice you fall violently
that's where precipitous comes from
right okay great but good english very
very good english bill
thank you guys everybody
[Music]
you